So we talked about page rank as a way
to.
Capture the authorities now we also
looked at the some other examples where
a hub might be interesting, so there is
another algorithm called hits and
that's going to compute the scores for
authorities and hubs.
Intuitions are pages that are wider.
Sites are good authorities, then where
pages that cite
many other pages are good hubs, right?
But the I think the most interesting
idea of this algorithm hits is.
It's going to use reinforcement
mechanism to kind of help improve the
scoring for hubs and authorities, and
here.
So here's the idea.
It would assume that good authorities
are cited by good hubs.
That means if you're cited by many
pages with good hub scores, then that
increases your authority score and
similarly good hubs are those that pointed
to good authorities.
So if you get you pointed to a lot of
good authority pages, then your hub
score will be increased.
So then we can iterate, reinforce each
other 'cause you can point to some good
hubs so that you can point to some good
authorities to get a good hub score,
whereas those authoritie scores.
Would be also improved because they are
pointed to by a good hub and this
algorithm is also general.
It can have many applications in graph
and network analysis.
So just briefly, here's how it works.
We first also construct the matrix, but
this time we're going to construct the
adjacency matrix and we're not going to
normalize the values.
So if there's a link, there is one.
If there's no link that's zero again it's
the same graph.
And then we're going to define the Hub
score of page as the sum of the
authority scores of all the pages that
it points to.
So whether you are a hub really
depends on whether you're pointing to a
lot of good authority pages.
That's what it says in the first
equation.
In the second equation, we define the
authorities score over page as the sum
of the hub scores of all those pages
that the point to you.
So whether you are good authoritie
would depend on whether those pages
that are pointing to you are good hubs
so you can see this forms iterative
reinforcement mechanism.
Now these two equations can be also
written in the matrix format.
I saw what we get here is then the hub
vector is equal to the product of the
edges of the adjacency matrix and the authority
vector.
And this is basically the first
equation right?
And similarly the second equation can
be returned as the authoritie vector is
equal to the product of A transpose
multiplied by the hub vector and
these are just different ways of
expressing these equations.
But what's interesting is that if you
look at the metrics form, you can also
plug in the authority equation.
Into the first one.
So if you do that, you can actually
then eliminate the authoritie vector
completely and you get the equation of
only hub scores, right?
The Hub score vector is equal to A * A
transpose multiplied by the hub score
vector again.
And similarly, we can do a
transformation to have equation for
just the authority scores.
So although we framed the problem as
computing hubs and authorities, we can
actually eliminate one of them to
obtain equation just for one of them.
The difference between this and page
rank is that now the matrix is actually
a multiplication of the edges in the
matrix and its transpose, so this is
different from page rank.
But mathematically, then we will be
computing the same problem.
So in hits we typically would
initialize the values that said, one
for all these values and then we would
iteratively apply these equations,
essentially and
This is equivalent to multiply that by
the Matrix A and A transpose.
So the algorithm is exactly the similar
page rank, but here because the
adjacency matrix is not normalized.
So what we have to do, what we have to
do is after each iteration, we're going
to normalize and this would allow us to
control the growth of value, otherwise
they would grow larger and larger.
And if we do that and then we'll
basically get hits algorithm to compute
the hub scores an authority scores for
all the pages.
And these scores can then be used in
ranking just like a page rank scores.
So to summarize, in this lecture we
have seen that link information is very
useful.
In particular, the anchor text is very
useful to increase the.
The text representation of a page and
we also talk about page rank and hits on
as two major link analysis algorithms.
Both can generate scores for web pages
that can be used in the ranking
function.
Note that page rank and it's also very
general algorithms, so they have many
applications in analyzing other graphs
or networks.